some will tell you that it's Adidas
after the German cobbler Adidas who
founded company but I have a secret to
tell you I visited the headquarters
where they have a framed copy of this
[Music]
single that of course is the first two
words of rund dmc's single from 1986 so
America you have permission to say
Adidas because rev Ron says it well yeah
okay duh but will you say Adidas Mark
King is brand new president of Adidas
North America in charge of selling a
European brand in a booming American
Market Mark help me understand why Move
Your Design headquarters for the entire
company from the Sleepy Hamlet of Herzog
now Rock Germany to
Brooklyn I think it's simple to make it
more relevant in the US I think we're
finding it very hard to be Miles and
Miles Away across an ocean and say we
can relate to high school kids the core
of the market is high school kids so I
think we've got to be here to be
relevant do you think that's actually
the challenge that Adidas has seen here
as a European brand or is it just not on
anybody's radar at all no I think it's
everything I I think European Brands
here that are really want to compete at
the highest level struggle because
there's a European mentality that comes
out of Germany and it's tried to you try
to apply it here it's very difficult
because of cultural issues and
difference in geography what is that
what are they getting
wrong I think everything I think we need
to focus more on the United States
consumer and athlete we have to be here
local which is what we're doing we're
moving a lot resources here I think it's
design I think it's the Nuance of
messaging uh we try to use a global
message around soccer or football and
try to make it relevant here and there's
so many sports here it's got to be here
now you're going to go after more
American Sports yeah so I mean the the
if you if you look uh let me pull up
this chart uh we're looking at Global
growth in in apparel over the last three
years you know and you can see Adidas of
course had a very good year in
2014 um or sorry that's still coming in
from some of that world cup earnings um
but what you see at the bottom there
that little blue blip is growing slowly
uh that's under armor um and those
numbers are much more that's those are
Global those numbers are much more
dramatic in North America what is Under
Armour doing right that you guys have to
get right well I I think what they have
over us right now is that they're here
in the United States and 90% of their
efforts are focused on the US the US is
45% of the global sporting market so
they're here they're relevant they're
they're touching consumers every day can
I mention that you are in the Hall of
Fame of the University of Wisconsin at
Green Bay I think that is the coolest
thing is that sports or academic I I
think it's both let me cut to the chase
here Nike and under what's it called
Under Armour are like these in America
Brands Adidas are these aat people over
in Germany that nobody wants to wear how
are you going to change that well I
honestly you need what's who's the
quarterback Rogers for the Green Bay
Aaron Rogers you need Aaron roders you
need Aaron Rodgers or somebody like that
to build your brand here we need more
relevance with us athletes we need more
relevance with design we need more
relevance with the messaging a lot of
your competitors have sort of aligned
themselves with Fitness movements
obviously L lemon is with yoga you've
seen Nike aligning itself with local
running groups you gach actually used to
do this with the sort of the Jane Fonda
uh step aerobics movement that Tom I
know you remember well what what
movement is idas going to align itself
with well we're all about Sport and
athletes and athletes train and they're
into fitness so to me it's really first
about the athlete and and then it's
really about this Fitness movement but
first it's the athlete then to Fitness
you you came to uh Adidas from tailor
made um and the biggest problems that
Adidas is having right now particularly
in the US are Reebok and Taylor Made its
other brands are is is Adidas finally
going to wrap those Brands into one big
Adidas brand that's universally
recognizable no I don't think so we made
a decision a long time ago you can go
monor branded or multi-branded we
believe that consumers have preference
es by Brands and I think there's there's
opportunities to build those Brands
individually then what are you going to
do to save those two Brands Taylor Made
rebok well first of all the Gulf
business I think is very different than
than the rebok business the Gulf
business actually has declined by about
20% the last two or three years the
health of that brand is still very
strong in terms of market share so I
think as we when we're investing a lot
of money in the industry to get more
people to play golf so that that's a
little bit different Reebok is a is very
very final is really pointed at Fitness
and
CrossFit UFC fighting all these
different ex all right rebok making a
move into CrossFit Adidas making a move
into Brooklyn Mark King CE of North
America for Adidas thank you